savile and Stewart Hall were serial
sexual predators Savile was a danger to
young people both girls and boys
opportunistic and shameless I have
identified 72 BBC victims of Savile of
whom 34 were under the age of 16 his
youngest victim was aged 8 his abuse
included 8 cases of rape the youngest
victim being only 10 years old
Stewart Hall targeted and groomed young
girls often plying them with alcohol
Dame Linda identified 21 victims of
abuse of whom 8 were girls under the age
of 16 the youngest was 10 both of these
men used their fame and positions as BBC
celebrities to abuse the vulnerable they
must be condemned for their monstrous
behavior but the culture of the BBC
certainly enabled both Savile and
Stewart Hall to go undetected for
decades I have identified five occasions
when the BBC missed an opportunity to
uncover their misconduct I want to leave
ample time for questions so I intend in
these opening remarks to address only
three central matters these are the
complicit effect of BBC culture the
question of who at the BBC could have
done something to stop the Savile and
Stewart Hall and finally I want to speak
to and about the victims but before that
I want to deal head-on with criticisms
that have arisen in recent weeks first
but no point has the BBC ever sought to
influence the reviews either as to the
content of my report
or as to the date of publication and if
it had I would have paid no heed second
the delay following the completion of
the report in April 2015 was due solely
to the concerns expressed by the
Metropolitan Police who feared the
publication might prejudice their
ongoing investigations there was no
other reason I come to the first of my
three main points the features of the
culture of the BBC which enable enabled
Savile and Stewart Hall to hide for
decades and for which I must criticize
the BBC there was a culture of not
complaining or of raising concerns BBC
staff felt and were sometimes told that
it was not in their best interests to
pursue a complaint loyalty to and pride
in a program could hinder the sharing of
concerns there was a reluctance to rock
the boat the management structure of the
BBC was not only hierarchical but deeply
deferential staff were reluctant to
speak out to their managers because they
felt it was not their place to do so
also there was a culture of separation
competition and even hostility between
different parts of the BBC so the
concerns arising in one part would not
be discussed with others it was also a
macho culture in particular in Radio 1
and right entertainment there were very
few women in management positions women
found it difficult to report sexual
harassment all the problems of reporting
were compounded in the case of the
talent celebrities were treated with kid
gloves and were virtually untouchable
one witness told me that the talent were
more valuable to the BBC than their own
values if these cultural factors had not
existed there would have been a real
chance of Savile and Stewart Hall being
discovered I do recognize that many of
these factors were common in the British
workplace and some still are but these
are all matters which the BBC must now
address most important of all in the
1970s 80s and 90s Child Protection was
very low on the BBC's radar in this the
BBC was far from alone at that time our
society did not recognize the prevalence
of the sexual abuse of children
complaints were disbelieved and
therefore rarely made we were not
sufficiently shocked by the signs of
older men being sexually involved with
teenage girls and we were unaware of the
damage which such unequal relations can
cause sexual harassment was not taken
seriously
the BBC's attitude to child protection
might have been understandable but for
one exceptional factor which makes it
deeply disturbing this related to Top of
the Pops in 1971 there were allegations
in the press about young girls being
picked up for sexual purposes on top of
the pops on pornographic pictures being
taken after the show
there were also press allegations of
corruption the reaction of the BBC is
illuminating it investigated the
corruption allegations of thoroughly but
it did not investigate the allegations
about the young girls with anything like
the same focus it was plainly concerned
about its reputation but was not
concerned to the same degree about what
should have been a wake-up call
that there were young girls who might be
exposed to moral danger on top of the
pops the BBC seemed to regard the young
audiences as necessary but a nuisance
one note of a management meeting
describes the girls as unbalanced there
was no sense that they were young and in
need of protection
so when complaints were made about
Savile by two teenage girls who were
assaulted on top of the pops their
complaints were not recorded or passed
upwards to management as they should
have been instead they were brushed
aside one girl was told to move out of
the way of the camera and the other was
ejected from the building and left on
the street the failure to heed these
complaints about Sabol amounted to two
missed opportunities to detect and stop
him I cannot say that proper
investigation of those complaints would
have resulted in prosecution but the BBC
would at least have become aware of
Sara's nature I turned to my next main
point who at the BBC could have done
something about Jimmy Savile and Stewart
Hall in respect of Savile there were
three individuals the first was Ted
Weston who was Savile's BBC Radio 1
producer on one occasion he was prepared
to act as a provider of a young woman to
Savile for sex
I found that he knew that Sarah would
have casual sex with teenage girls as
and when he could get it although he
denied it I'm satisfied that mr. besten
must have realised from their appearance
that some of the girls might well be
underage he admired Savile and I do not
think it ever crossed his mind that he
should report him but he should have
done
the second was cannon callin semper he
was a producer in the religious
broadcasting department and worked
closely with several with commendable
honesty when giving evidence to the
review he accepted that he had come to
think that Savile had casual sex with a
lot of girls some of whom might have
been underage he did not discuss what he
knew with his managers because he
thought that they already knew about
Savile and did not seem to be concerned
about it in my view he should have
discussed his concerns with his line
manager I think he now deeply regrets
that he did not the third is Douglas
Muggeridge the controller of Radio one
and two in the early 1970s mr. Mockridge
died many years ago in 1973 he heard
rumors about several sexual activities
and prompted some inquiries
Savile was asked about the rumors and
denied them I think mr. Muggeridge
genuinely believed the rumors to be
untrue however in my view he should have
retained his concerns should have shared
them with colleagues and had a watch
kept on Savile had he done so Savile
might well have been uncovered in the
1970s this was a third missed
opportunity although I have found that
none of several senior managers in
television were aware of his sexual
misconduct
I do criticize them in another important
respect by 1983 there was a good deal of
material in the public domain which
showed Savile in a very bad light
whatever the truth about him this
material showed Savile boasting of past
associations with violent criminals and
proud to be described as having a
prolific
all sex life with young women many
decades younger than himself it is
amazing that it never occurred to
severals managers of the BBC that on
account of this they should not give him
a platform to promote his image as a
good man it is amazing that it never
occurred to them that Savile was not a
suitable role model for the young
audiences of Gemmell Fixit in Manchester
there were two individuals who could
have done something to stop Stewart Hall
Raymond Kali and Tom German Raymond Kali
was the regional television manager in
Manchester from 1970 until 1986 Dame
Linda found that when mr. Kali took up
his post he challenged Stuart Hall about
rumours that he was having sex with
women in his dressing room these rumors
did not suggest that these were underage
girls Mr Colley warned Stuart Hall as to
his future conduct but he did not follow
up his warning he assumed that Stuart
Hall would desist he overestimated his
own authority and he underestimated
Stuart Hall's duplicity had mr. Kali
kept a watch on Hall it is likely that
he would have been stopped this was the
first missed opportunity in respect of
Stuart Hall the fourth overall mr.
German was the news editor in Manchester
during the 1970s and 80s he is dead
Dame Linda has concluded that he was
probably aware that Stuart Hall was
involved in inappropriate sexual conduct
on BBC premises if he was it seems to me
that he should have shared his concerns
with mr. Kali he did not do so and this
may well have been the fifth missed
opportunity this report makes sorry
reading for the BBC
Dame Linda and I have found disturbing
things and have not hesitated to expose
them from a conversation I had with Lord
Hall on Tuesday after he had read my
report I am satisfied that he entirely
accepts but there is much work ahead for
him the BBC Trust and the Executive
Board if the BBC is to regain the
confidence of the public in respect of
its culture and its child protection
practices I wish now to speak about the
victims I must record my annoyance at
the complete wreck
disregard of their welfare shown by a
website that chose to publish parts of
an early draft of my report this
unexpected and selective publication was
highly distressing for them and had no
public interest justification whatsoever
I want to thank every witness who gave
evidence to me enter Dame Linda
but above all I want to send a personal
message to the victims of Seville and
Stuart Hall many of whom will be
listening thank you for your
contribution and your courage some of
you have told me and Dame Linda that you
blame yourselves for what happened and
for not reporting it at the time you are
not to blame and your reasons for not
reporting are wholly understandable I
know that it was very difficult for you
to speak to the review you did so in
order to help us understand what had
happened and why it had not been
discovered society owes you a great debt
your legacy is that you have helped to
convince us all of the importance of
ensuring that young and vulnerable
people have the confidence to report
abuse and that when they do so their
voices will be heard
and treated with the same respect as
those who hold power in our society I
think that is a legacy of which you can
be justifiably proud thank you